Seção 4 de Dom Casmurro.
Esta é uma gravação LibriVox. Todas as gravações LibriVox estão em domínio público. Para mais informações ou para ser um voluntário, por favor visite: librivox.org. Gravado por Raquel Morais.
Dom Casmurro, de Machado de Assis. Seção 4.
Capítulo 16. O administrador interino. Pádua era empregado em repartição dependente do Ministério da Guerra. Não trabalhava muito, mas a mulher gastava pouco, e a vida era barata. Demais, a casa em que morava, assobradada como a nossa, posto que menor, era propriedade dele; comprou-a com a sorte grande, que lhe saiu num meio bilhete de loteria: dez contos de réis.
A primeira ideia do Pádua, quando lhe saiu o prêmio, foi comprar um cavalo do cabo, um adereço de brilhantes para a mulher, uma sepultura perpétua de família, mandar vir da Europa alguns pássaros, etc. Mas a mulher, esta Dona Fortunata, que ali está à porta dos fundos da casa, em pé, falando à filha — alta, forte e cheia como a filha, a mesma cabeça, os mesmos olhos claros — a mulher é que lhe disse que o melhor era comprar a casa e guardar o que sobrasse para acudir às moléstias grandes. Pádua hesitou muito; afinal teve de ceder aos conselhos de minha mãe, a quem Dona Fortunata pediu auxílio. Nem foi só nessa ocasião que minha mãe lhes valeu; um dia chegou a salvar a vida ao Pádua. Escutai; a anedota é curta.
O administrador da repartição em que Pádua trabalhava teve de ir ao Norte em comissão. Pádua, ou por ordem regulamentar ou por especial designação, ficou substituindo o administrador com os respectivos honorários. Esta mudança de fortuna trouxe-lhe certa vertigem. Era antes dos dez contos. Não se contentou de reformar a roupa e a copa; atirou-se às despesas supérfluas, deu joias à mulher, nos dias de festa matava um leitão, era visto em teatros, chegou aos sapatos de verniz. Viveu assim vinte e dois meses na suposição de uma eterna interinidade. Uma tarde, entrou em nossa casa, aflito e desvairado: ia perder o lugar, porque chegara o efetivo naquela manhã. Pediu a minha mãe que lhe velasse pelas infelizes que deixava, não podia sofrer a desgraça, matava-se. Minha mãe falou-lhe com bondade, mas ele não atendia a cousa nenhuma.
— Não, minha senhora, não consentirei em tal vergonha, fazer descer a família, tornar atrás. Já disse, mato-me. Não hei de confessar à minha gente esta miséria. E os outros? Que dirão os vizinhos? E os amigos? E o público?
— Que público, Sr. Pádua? Deixe-se disso, seja homem. Lembre-se que sua mulher não tem outra pessoa, e que há de fazer? Pois um homem... seja homem, ande.
Pádua enxugou os olhos e foi para casa, onde viveu prostrado alguns dias, mudo, fechado na alcova, ou então no quintal, ao pé do poço, como se a ideia da morte teimasse nele. Dona Fortunata ralhava: "Joãozinho, você é criança?" Mas tanto lhe ouviu falar em morte, que teve medo, e um dia correu a pedir a minha mãe que lhe fizesse o favor de ver se lhe salvava o marido, que se queria matar. Minha mãe foi achá-lo à beira do poço e intimou-lo que vivesse. Que maluquice era aquela de parecer que ia ficar desgraçado por causa de uma gratificação a menos, e perder o emprego interino? Não, senhor, devia ser homem, pai de família, imitar a mulher e a filha. Pádua obedeceu, confessou que acharia forças para cumprir a vontade de minha mãe. "Vontade minha, não, é obrigação sua!" Pois seja obrigação, não desconheço que é assim mesmo.
Nos dias seguintes, continuou a entrar e a sair de casa cosido à parede, cara no chão; não era o mesmo homem que estragava o chapéu em cortejar a vizinhança, risonho, olhos no ar, antes mesmo da administração interina. Vieram as semanas, a ferida foi sarando. Pádua começou a interessar-se pelos negócios domésticos, a cuidar dos passarinhos, a dormir tranquilo as noites e as tardes, a conversar e dar notícias da rua. A serenidade regressou, atrás dela veio a alegria, um domingo, na figura de dois amigos que iam jogar o solo, atentos. Já ele ria, já brincava, tinha o ar do costume. A ferida sarou de todo.
Com o tempo, veio um fenômeno interessante. Pádua começou a falar da administração interina não somente sem as saudades dos honorários nem o vexame da perda, mas até com desvanecimento e orgulho. A administração ficou sendo a égide donde ele contava para diante e para trás: "No tempo em que eu era administrador...", ou então: "Ah, sim, lembra-me, foi antes da minha administração, um ou dois meses antes; ora espere, a minha administração começou... é isto, mês e meio antes, foi mês e meio antes, não foi mais." Ou ainda: "Justamente, havia já seis meses que eu o administrava." Tal é o sabor póstumo das glórias interinas. José Dias bradava que era vaidade sobrevivente, mas o Padre Cabral, que levava tudo para a Escritura, dizia que com o vizinho Pádua se dava a lição de Elifaz a Jó: "Não desprezes a correção do Senhor, ele fere e cura."
Capítulo 17. Os vermes. Ele fere e cura. Quando, mais tarde, vim a saber que a lança de Aquiles também curou uma ferida que fez, tive tais ou quais veleidades de escrever uma dissertação a este propósito. Cheguei a pegar em livros velhos, livros mortos, livros enterrados, a abri-los e compará-los, calando o texto e o sentido, para achar a origem comum do oráculo pagão e do pensamento israelita. Catei os próprios vermes dos livros, para que me dissessem o que havia nos textos roídos por eles.
— Meu senhor, respondeu-me um longo verme gordo, uns não sabemos absolutamente nada dos textos que roemos, nem escolhemos o que roemos, nem amamos ou detestamos o que roemos; nós roemos.
Não lhe arranquei mais nada. Os outros todos, como se houvessem passado palavra, repetiam a mesma cantilena. Talvez esse discreto silêncio sobre os textos roídos fosse ainda um modo de roer o roído.
Capítulo 18. Um plano. Pai nem mãe foram ter conosco quando Capitu e eu, na sala de visitas, falávamos do seminário. Com os olhos em mim, Capitu queria saber que notícia era aquela que me afligia tanto. Quando lhe disse o que era, fez-se cor de cera.
— Mas eu não quero, acudi logo, não quero entrar em seminário, não entro, é escusado teimarem comigo, não entro. Capitu a princípio não disse nada. Recolheu os olhos, meteu-os em si, e deixou-se estar com as pupilas vagas e surdas, a boca entreaberta, toda parada. Então eu, para dar forças às afirmações, comecei a jurar que não seria padre. Naquele tempo jurava muito e rijo, pela vida e pela morte. Jurei pela hora da morte; que a luz me faltasse na hora da morte se fosse para o seminário. Capitu não parecia crer nem descrer, não parecia sequer ouvir; era uma figura de pau. Quis chamá-la, sacudi-la, mas faltou-me ânimo. Essa criatura que brincara comigo, que pulara, dançara, creio até que dormira comigo, deixava-me agora com os braços atados e medrosos. Enfim, tornou a si, mas tinha a cara lívida, e rompeu nestas palavras furiosas:
— Beata! Carola! Papa-missas!
Fiquei atordilhado. Capitu gostava tanto de minha mãe e minha mãe dela, que eu não podia entender tamanha explosão. É verdade que também gostava de mim, e naturalmente mais, ou de outra maneira, cousa bastante a explicar o despeito que lhe trazia a ameaça da separação. Mas os impropérios, como entender que lhe chamasse nomes tão feios, e principalmente para deprimir costumes religiosos que eram os seus? Que ela também ia à missa, e três ou quatro vezes minha mãe é que a levou, na nossa velha sedia. Também lhe dera um rosário, uma cruz de ouro e um livro de horas. Quis defendê-la, mas Capitu não me deixou; continuou a chamar-lhe beata e carola em voz tão alta que tive medo fosse ouvida dos pais. Nunca a vi tão irritada como então; parecia disposta a dizer tudo a todos. Cerrava os dentes, abanava a cabeça; eu, assustado, não sabia que fizesse. Repetia os juramentos, prometia ir naquela mesma noite declarar em casa que por nada neste mundo entraria no seminário.
— Você? Você entra. — Não entro. — Você verá se entra ou não.
Calou-se outra vez. Quando tornou a falar, tinha mudado. Não era ainda a Capitu do costume, mas quase. Estava séria, sem aflição, falava baixo. Quis saber a conversação da minha casa. Eu contei-lhe a toda, menos a parte que lhe dizia respeito.
— E que interesse tem José Dias em lembrar isto? perguntou-me no fim. — Acho que nenhum; foi só para fazer mal. É um sujeito muito ruim. Mas deixe estar que me há de pagar. Quando eu for dono da casa, quem vai para a rua é ele, você verá; não me fica um instante. Mamãe é boa demais, dá-lhe atenção demais. Parece até que chorou.
— José Dias? — Não, mamãe. — Chorou por quê? — Não sei, ouvi-o só dizer que ela não chorasse, que não era cousa de choro. Ele chegou a mostrar-se arrependido e saiu; eu então, para não ser apanhado, deixei o canto e corri para a varanda. Mas deixe estar que ele me paga.
Disse isto fechando o punho e proferi outras ameaças; ao relembrá-las, não me acho ridículo. A adolescência e a infância não são neste ponto ridículas; é um dos seus privilégios. Esse mal ou esse perigo começa na mocidade, cresce na madureza e atinge o maior grau na velhice. Aos quinze anos, há até certa graça em ameaçar muito e não executar nada. Capitu refletia. A reflexão não era cousa rara nela, e conheciam-se as ocasiões pelo apertado dos olhos. Pediu-me algumas circunstâncias mais, as próprias palavras de uns e de outros, e o tom delas. Como eu não queria dizer o ponto inicial da conversa, que era ela mesma, não lhe pude dar toda a significação.
— E que interesse tem José Dias? repetiu. Acho que nenhum. Foi só para fazer mal. É um sujeito muito ruim. Mas deixe estar que ele me paga. Quando eu for dono da casa, quem vai para a rua é ele, você verá; não me fica um instante. Mamãe é boa demais, dá-lhe atenção demais. Parece até que chorou. — José Dias? — Não, mamãe. — Chorou por quê? — Não sei, ouvi-o só dizer que ela não chorasse, que não era cousa de choro. Ele chegou a mostrar-se arrependido e saiu; eu então, para não ser apanhado, deixei o canto e corri para a varanda. Mas deixe estar que ele me paga.
— Pode ser um bom empenho. — Mas se foi ele mesmo que falou? — Não importa, continuou Capitu. Dirá agora outra coisa; ele gosta muito de você. Não lhe fale acanhado, tudo é que você não tenha medo, mostre que há de vir a ser dono da casa, mostra que quer e que pode; dê-lhe bem a entender que não é favor. Faça-lhe também elogios, ele gosta muito de ser elogiado. A Dona Glória presta-lhe atenção, mas o principal não é isso; é que ele, tendo de servir a você, falará com muito mais calor que outra pessoa.
— Não acho não, Capitu. — Então vá para o seminário! — Isso não! — Mas que se perde em experimentar? Experimentemos. Faça o que lhe digo. Dona Glória pode ser que mude de resolução; se não mudar, faz-se outra cousa, mete-se então o Padre Cabral. Você não se lembra como é que foi ao teatro pela primeira vez há dois meses? Dona Glória não queria, e bastava isso para que José Dias não teimasse. Mas ele queria ir, e fez um discurso, lembra-se?
— Lembra-me, disse que o teatro era uma escola de costumes. — Justo! Tanto falou, que sua mãe acabou consentindo. E pagou a entrada aos dois. Ande, peça, mande. Olhe, diga-lhe que está pronto a ir estudar leis em São Paulo.
Estremeci de prazer. São Paulo era um frágil biombo destinado a ser arredado um dia, em vez da grossa parede espiritual e eterna. Prometi falar a José Dias nos termos propostos. Capitu repetiu-os, acentuando alguns como principais, e inquiriu-me depois sobre eles, a ver se entendera bem, se não trocara uns por outros. E insistia em que pedisse com boa cara, mas assim como quem pede um copo de água à pessoa que tem obrigação de o trazer. Conto estas minúcias para que melhor se entenda aquela manhã da minha amiga. Logo virá a tarde, e da manhã e da tarde se fará o primeiro dia, como no Gênesis, onde se fizeram sucessivamente sete.
Capítulo 19. Sem falta. Quando voltei a casa era noite. Vim depressa, não tanto, porém, que não pensasse nos termos em que falaria ao agregado. Formulei o pedido de cabeça, escolhendo as palavras que diria e o tom delas, entre seco e benévolo. Na chácara, antes de entrar em casa, repetia-as comigo, depois em voz alta, para ver se eram adequadas e se obedeciam às recomendações de Capitu.
"Preciso falar-lhe sem falta, sem falta, amanhã. Escolha o lugar e diga-me." Proferi-as lentamente, e mais lentamente ainda as palavras "sem falta", como para sublinhá-las. Repetia-as ainda, e então achei-as secas demais, quase ríspidas, e francamente impróprias de uma criançola para um homem maduro. Cuidei de escolher outras e parei. Afinal disse comigo que as palavras podiam servir, tudo era dizê-las em tom que não ofendesse. E a prova é que, repetindo-as novamente, saíram-me quase súplices. Bastava não carregar tanto, nem adoçar muito: um meio-termo. E Capitu tem razão, pensei, a casa é minha, ele é um simples agregado; jeitoso é, pode muito bem trabalhar por mim e desfazer o plano de mamãe.
Capítulo 20. Mil Padre-Nossos e mil Ave-Marias. Levantei os olhos ao céu, que começava a embruscar-se, mas não foi para vê-lo coberto ou descoberto. Era ao outro céu que eu erguia a minha alma, era ao meu refúgio, ao meu amigo. E então disse de mim para mim:
"Prometo rezar mil Padre-Nossos e mil Ave-Marias, se José Dias arranjar que eu não vá para o seminário." A soma era enorme. A razão é que eu andava carregado de promessas não cumpridas. A última foi de duzentos Padre-Nossos e duzentas Ave-Marias, se não chovesse em certa tarde de passeio a Santa Teresa. Não choveu, mas eu não rezei as orações. Desde pequenino acostumara-me a pedir aos céus os seus favores mediante orações que diria se eles viessem. Disse as primeiras, as outras foram adiadas, e à medida que se amontoavam, iam sendo esquecidas. Assim cheguei aos números vinte, trinta, cinquenta; entrei nas centenas, e agora no milhar. Era um modo de peitar a vontade divina pela quantia das orações. Além disso, cada promessa nova era feita e jurada no sentido de pagar a dívida antiga. Mas vão lá matar a preguiça de uma alma que a trazia do berço e não a sentia atenuada pela vida. O céu fazia-me o favor; eu adiava a paga. Afinal perdi-me nas contas. "Mil, mil", repeti comigo. Realmente a matéria do benefício era agora imensa, não menos que a salvação ou naufrágio da minha existência inteira. "Mil, mil, mil!" Era preciso uma soma que pagasse os atrasados todos. Deus podia muito bem, irritado com os esquecimentos, negar-se a ouvir-me sem muito dinheiro.
Homem grave, é possível que essas agitações de menino te enfadem, se é que não as aches ridículas. Sublimes não eram. Cogitei muito no modo de resgatar a dívida espiritual. Não achava outra espécie em que mediante a intenção tudo se cumprisse, fechando a escrituração da minha consciência moral sem déficit. Mandar dizer cem missas ou subir de joelhos a Ladeira da Glória para ouvir uma, ir à Terra Santa, tudo o que as velhas escravas me contavam de promessas célebres. Tudo me acudia sem se fixar de vez no espírito. Era muito duro subir uma ladeira de joelhos; devia feri-los por força. A Terra Santa ficava muito longe. As missas eram numerosas; podiam empenhar-me outra vez a alma.